hi everybody welcome back
to the big dance spectacular my first
guests tonight refer to themselves as
ripoff artiste
illusion
their show penn tower's sin city
spectacular airs each friday at 10
o'clock p.m on the fx channel ladies and
gentlemen please welcome a pen and
teller hello
now you know what
you uh
you did that whole thing on magician or
illusionist i started out actually as a
juggler you were a juggler yeah when
people think of juggling they think of
this kind of toss juggling okay they're
all sorts of other kinds of juggling i
want to demonstrate something before you
get a little bit out of the way those
are sharps yes well you'll see there
it's part of the western arch there's a
thing called
knife throwing
as part of the whole uh you know oops
that was nice bouncing right there but
it's part of the whole you know whip
cracking and rope spinning that was cool
that looks great they look really great
but the problem is when you do knife
throwing like this it gets a little bit
dull so over the ages the carnies have
found ways to make it more interesting
and one of the ways what's called the
human target and it's best to have
someone that people at home can relate
to like for instance you so why don't
you step right over here okay against
the tar you're not the usual model we
use but you can kind of you can just
kind of look like that a little a little
little bit for you wait do i have to
strike her exactly
i don't think you can i don't think you
can strike her exactly but just just try
to get this
good all right just and look straight
ahead i'm going to count to three one
two three
are you really throwing those at me yeah
on the imaginary four i will let go of
the all you gotta do is stay still code
and this is mostly me okay wait a minute
i missed that second one with
that shut up probably the best if you
shut up one
two many viewers say that no way
well then let's just talk for a second
those look really sharp they told me uh
don't come to rehearsal or anything
and now i understand why no see what you
did though was you were talking you were
trying to keep the show moving that's
very important right but as soon as you
saw me pull my hand back you did this
which i'm not saying was unattractive
i'm just saying that when you did that
you pulled your elbow down right right i
got to stay still the problem was i was
aiming for here and i know the way you
are you'd be saying oh pen stuck a knife
in my arm you wouldn't be saying pen did
a perfect throw and i moved my arm into
the path so you wouldn't let's just do
this this will put the blindfold on then
you'll be much less apt to flinch but
wait i i saw you throw
i saw you throw three of these and and
one of them it just was really crappy
yeah i know but i got warmed up now did
anyone else notice that that one please
don't move god didn't really i'm serious
now please gonna don't move and what oh
wait a minute hold on
stupid one way two
three
huh nice take a look take a look come on
take a look
take your blindfold robot number five
again one
that was very good that was very good
pull me up pull the blindfold down conan
you got another one to do
pull that
there you go and get that i'll get that
arm up and uh here again yeah right here
again i'm not gonna aim for the same
side but if if you're in that position
that's what i'm used to conan just here
we go does it hurt you if i wet myself
just don't move your right arm
especially now conan one two three huh
out there
yeah you know take a look there cody
take the left
nicely done nicely done
it scared me a little bit
you scared me a little bit cloning
because you put this arm out a little
bit right as i was throwing it that
scared you scared me uh my heart went
through this have been sheer terror for
you
pull down the blindfold why do we have
to do more two
two great comedies and threes conan
comedy yeah okay
pull it down there there we go and where
am i i gotta get my female position
don't worry that much about that we're
going near the head this time
so the arms are much less crucial now
but do stay still i'm not gonna remember
irish heads are wider than most other
heads
why okay wait a minute
okay one two three
okay take a look go ahead take a look
i think i think you're a natural-born
target nicely done donald natural-born
target beautifully done
now cody
do you watch the show
watch my own show no so you want to
cause i i don't want you got cable i
don't have to i don't want you to
i don't want you to leave because you
knew we were doing something fishy and i
don't want you to act like i don't know
how that works i'm guessing you weren't
really throwing right i wasn't really
throwing i want to show you the uh the
way this works in the gag if you'll see
behind here conan there are
electromagnets powerful electric turn
them on would you please robbie and when
i throw a knife up against it let it go
robbie it just sticks right there and
all i got to do turn it on bobby
is get it in the general let it go
get in the general vicinity and that
electromagnet will pull it right into
place so really anyone can throw knives
which as a matter of fact conan
you want to throw you sure it works like
really i just yeah step over here to
line come on i don't know
just put your left you're right-handed
uh yeah put your left foot on the line
left foot on the left put your right
foot back a little bit okay take the
knife here connor right and all you got
to do is no no from the handle from the
handle but isn't it cool to throw it
like that like that
that's if you're a lot closer that's
like shooting the gun sideways you look
cool but you miss
so uh right back i hope i don't miss no
you won't miss it it's all done and all
you got to do now i'm not counting for
you i'm counting for robbie and it's
very important one two three and throw
on the imaginary four okay and the
electromagnets we'll just suck it right
in we'll suck right in look here we go
you all said coda uh
just we're gonna do it yeah all right
okay you're sure paul can i really throw
it hard or not too hard just hard enough
for it to get here you don't want to
over over okay let's go all right all
right all right and ready and i'm gonna
go wide i mean you know i'm not sure
you're not supposed to have control of
it it's supposed to be the magnet okay
okay okay so don't try to do anything
just ready just go baby go one
two three conan come on um what did i do
i was no that looks very cool what i was
doing when you first started when i
first started counting you're looking in
the general area right as soon as i hit
two your attention were right to my
mouth i have and what you're gonna do is
you're gonna put some torque on it right
okay and that's going to throw off the
magnet so i want you to let me put the
blindfold on you again you don't want me
to put the block yeah then you can throw
much better do people want to see me
throw a knife at you with a blind oh
it's much more impressive don't you
think they do sure okay we're going to
throw this kind of on no kidding around
just do it nice and even right on the
floor actually you're holding it like a
like a pencil just really grip it down
like a baseball like a very sharp metal
baseball there you go we still want you
to let go off we're really going to go
this time conan and ready and one
two three all right throw throw it watch
it just throw it throw it down
do it go okay good good take a look
conan take a look nicely done conan
nicely done you're right there
let's do it let's do it what you're
hold the blindfold down put them right
there i am really good at it very good
in the corner i kicked you ass and the
same thing but just time don't block
really do throw on four makes it easier
you sure okay i just don't want okay i'm
fine it's fine we gotta i trust you here
okay one two three drop oh geez
i guess uh
another half inch higher you would have
really got me i
i guess it was the best i wasn't
standing there yeah
that was the last place you were looking
i guess going in uh
let me do uh
let me do one more pull do the math at
home people pull that down let's do uh
let's do one one more for you here you
go you got your okay here we go you're
sure it's like i'm positive now really
uh really let it rip this time uh let it
rip this time come on and
one two
three
throw pull
down
go
and don't watch the show
wait let me see that
and andy you've got nothing to say to
him you shut up
okay first as far as he knows he was
throwing knives
i was worried for like a millisecond
that maybe i hurt you
until i saw this
you guys got to get some better fakes
it's cold in the studio we didn't want
to mess up the the vest for you here
it's like a blood yarmulke here all
right
spend more money on that i'm sorry i
don't know what happened there i watched
the tape you shade around and uh thank
you very much it's always fun pen and
tell everybody treat williams coming up
with you right back